est-ce que vous trouvez qu'il y a une
vraie évolution du monde depuis la
création de youporn
de toute façon le le porno date de Adam
et je vois simplement vous connaissez
youporn ils étaient tous
bonsoir Michel Serres vous êtes
philosophe membre de l'Académie
française vous avez 82 ans si ça se
trouve vous êtes le seul immortel
vraiment immortel
bonsoir vous êtes philosophe
épistémologue
professeur à l'Université de Stanford en
Californie membre de l'Académie
française et vous êtes l'auteur du livre
petite poussette qui caracole en tête
des ventes depuis plusieurs mois 100 000
exemplaires Michel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors vous dites Michel en fait trop
engagé depuis Sartre dans la politique
les philosophes n'ont pas vu l'ampleur
du changement du monde et un philosophe
qui n'anticipe pas c'est un historien
je suis pas mal au soleil bien entendu
mais l'essentiel c'est de percevoir les
signaux faibles par exemple il y a 50
ans il était remarquable que société
allait changer qu'elle ne serait plus de
société purement de production mais de
communication et à ce moment-là j'ai
écrit évidemment les lieux qui
s'appellent Hermès dont petite poussette
n'est que la petite fille voilà vous
avez été pratiquement le premier à dire
ça mais seulement quand vous le dites 5
ans il y a 50 ans personne ne vous
entend il faut toujours une inertie
sociale un peu déterminée pour finir par
être entendu à l'époque on vous a
beaucoup critiqué vous avez été bien sûr
j'ai même été foutu d'heure de la philo
alors vous dites nous sommes aujourd'hui
en présence de nouveaux humains qui
cohabitent avec les anciens humains que
nous sommes j'appelle le grand papa
ronchon et petite poussette il y a deux
populations alors les nouveaux humains
sont les enfants du numérique comme
petite poussette vous dites c'est une
intelligence supérieure c'est une autre
intelligence c'est à dire que par
exemple le mot maintenant tout je crois
que ça veut dire aujourd'hui c'est
maintenant ça veut dire tenant en main
tenant
vous prenez votre portable et petite
poussette dit maintenant tenants
tous les lieux avec
GPS ou alors elle tient en main toutes
les informations avec Wikipédia et des
moteurs de recherche et il tient quand
même toutes les personnes parce qu'il y
a un théorème de mathématiques qui dit
que n'importe qui peut appeler n'importe
qui dans le monde en quatre coups de
téléphone on appelle ça le théorème du
petit monde par conséquent petite
poussette dit maintenant tenant en main
le monde mais qui pouvait dire
maintenant quand même le monde il y a à
peine 1000 ans ben si auguste empereur
de Rome vous pouvez dire ça Louis XIV
vous pouvez dire ça un milliardaire
américain pouvait dire ça attention
maintenant il y a 3 milliards de petites
poussettes dans le monde qui peuvent
dire maintenant tenant en main le monde
et ça c'est de l'utopie politique
parfaite
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce que ça nous
promet moi du coup je voulais vous
demander est-ce que vous trouvez qu'il y
a une vraie évolution du monde depuis la
création de youporn
de toute façon cette création date de
l'origine des temps je m'excuse le porno
date de Adam et je vois simplement vous
connaissez youporn il était ok moi je
connaissez pas youporn
et à la fumette
il fait pas peur un petit poussette non
non parce que petite vous êtes aussi à
une caractéristique c'est à dire les
médias type télé ou type radio c'est peu
d'émetteur et beaucoup de récepteurs la
toile c'est l'inverse c'est autant de
récepteurs que des metteurs et par
conséquent ça change complètement la
donne y compris la vôtre ça sert plus à
rien de faire un animalerie bien sûr
parce que quand il y a peu d'émetteur
peu de gens peuvent tenir en main
l'émission et maintenant c'est plus
possible parce que vous travaillez sur
la volonté de faire prendre conscience
aux gens du nouveau pouvoir c'est le
sujet de petit c'est le sujet de petites
poussées
que chacun maintenant le monde mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire de son
pouvoir petite poussette alors ça je
suis pas Madame Soleil je peux faire de
l'anticipation mais je peux pas dire
quel type de pouvoir ou comment
s'organisera son pouvoir alors c'est
extraordinaire de voir le seul mec de 82
ans à être excité parce que peuvent
apporter les smartphones mais
franchement vous le trouvez comment ce
21e siècle nous avait expliqué que ce
serait des des voitures volantes et
finalement il y a toujours Michel
Drucker quoi ça
non mais sérieux ça change pas ça change
pas vraiment
ça change et ça change pas c'est à dire
que dans l'ordinateur qui est le couple
support message c'est la troisième
révolution qui arrive la première ça a
été l'écriture la seconde ça a été
l'imprimerie et maintenant c'est la
nouvelle mais réfléchissez à ce qui
s'est passé dans les deux révolutions en
question tout a été transformé le droit
à la politique la science la religion et
tout et ce qui est en crise aujourd'hui
c'est précisément ce que cette
révolution est en crise c'est à dire
tout et par conséquent le 21e siècle
c'est ça c'est précisément ce qui se
passe grâce à ces nouvelles technologies
vous trouvez pas que l'avenir c'était
mieux avant quand même non ça c'est
grand papa ronchon qui dit ça et c'était
mieux avant et je lui réponds oui nous
avons été gouvernés que par les braves
gens Franco Mussolini Hitler Staline
Lénine Mao c'est tout mais pour le pot
c'était parfait c'était que des braves
gens c'était pas beaucoup mieux avant il
y a eu 100 millions de morts c'était
beaucoup mieux avant nous sommes en paix
depuis 65 ans cher ami oui mais cette
génération de petite poussette qui va
changer le monde c'est quand même celle
qui se marre en tapant lol et qui écrit
ça va avec un slime c'est-à-dire elle va
pas changer le monde le monde a déjà
changé voyons réveillez-vous mon cher
j'adore
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu